is Selena Gomez subtly shading Kim
kardashian-west
the singer took to her Instagram story
to share a photo of herself wearing
Kim's new shapewear collection skins so
we'll get a praise Kim's line writing on
screen quote legit so freakin
comfortable comfortable and free more
than I've ever felt in my whole life but
this is why we can't have nice things
the Swifty's for Taylor Swift's
ride-or-die fans slammed Selena for
wearing Kim's line when we know Taylor
and Kim haven't exactly gotten along in
the past one fan wrote quote the fact
that Selena is promoting skins girl what
are you doing they'll lose you to love
me singer quickly took the post down and
replaced it with the photo of her and
Taylor instead she thanked BFF Taylor
for quote forever being by my side and
reassured her by writing I'm on your
side for life I'm so proud of her I've
known her for eight years and she would
come to any of my premieres of a movie
she'd do anything for me I think it's
amazing to empower women I think it's
great that she brings people together
like that selena has never been shy
about praising Taylor in interviews she
recently sat down with Zane Lowe and
apples beats one podcast where she
opened up about how much Taylor's
loyalty means to her what kind of friend
has she been to you through those times
amazing for sure she was frustrated when
I was frustrated she was sad when I was
sad um but more than anything my friends
stood by my side when I think they
visibly saw me in so much pain and they
didn't want it for me but they sorry
oh no it's um they never stopped loving
me and that love is so mutual beauty
spoke with Selena and April and she
couldn't help but gush over her girls
specifically cardi B I'm obsessed with
her she's so sweet and she's very honest
and I respect me
what is that friendship mean to you it's
great because I I felt like when we got
to work on the video we were able to be
there for a while and there was no
pressure everything was super laid back
I just
she's hilarious and she brings a fiery
and energy into anything you always
inspire and encourage your female
friends cardi Taylor you excited for her
music oh yeah oh my goodness it's
amazing you just wait
[Music]